AI was supposed to take over the parts of the job you hate. Turns out, it made your job even harder. Instead of doing the work, it gave you homework. ServiceNow's AI specialists get work done from start to finish. Cases get resolved. Loops get closed. With ServiceNow, you can do the parts of your job you're best at and delegate the rest. To put AI to work for people, visit servicenow.com.
AI原本应该帮你处理那些你讨厌的工作。结果却发现，它让你的工作变得更难了。它没有帮你干活，反而给你布置了家庭作业。ServiceNow的AI专家能够从头到尾帮你完成工作。问题得到解决，流程得以闭环。借助ServiceNow，你可以专注于你最擅长的工作，把剩下的交出去。想要让AI真正为人服务，请访问servicenow.com。
Most of us don't lack creative ideas. Think about the last time. you solved a problem in an unexpected way. Maybe you figured out a shortcut at work or improvised a meal from the leftovers in your fridge. We don't always label those everyday moments as creative, though. Instead, we think of creativity as making art or music, and we assume that it's something you're born with, not something you can cultivate. But psychologists' research suggests that creativity isn't just about flashes of brilliance or artistic talent. It's about how we approach problems, respond to challenges and turn our ideas into reality.
我们大多数人并不缺乏创意。想想看，你上一次用出乎意料的方式解决问题是在什么时候。也许你在工作中想出了一个捷径，或者用冰箱里的剩菜临时拼凑了一顿饭。不过，我们并不总是把这些日常生活中的时刻贴上“有创意”的标签。相反，我们认为创造力就是创作艺术或音乐，并且我们认为这是天生具有的，而不是后天可以培养的。但心理学家的研究表明，创造力不仅仅是灵光一现或艺术天赋。它关乎我们如何看待问题、应对挑战，以及如何将我们的想法变为现实。
So what does it mean to be creative? What gets in the way of creative thinking and how can we move past those barriers? How do emotions and our social environments shape our creativity? What is human creativity worth in a world being reshaped by AI? And how can you move your creative ideas out of your head and into the world? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
那么，拥有创造力意味着什么？是什么阻碍了我们的创意思维，我们又该如何跨越这些障碍？情绪和我们的社会环境是如何塑造我们的创造力的？在一个正在被AI重塑的世界里，人类的创造力价值何在？你又该如何将脑海中的创意付诸实践，带入现实？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客节目，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Zorana Ichevich Pringle. Dr. Pringle is a senior research scientist and director of the Creativity and Emotions Lab at the Yale Center for Emotional Intelligence, where she studies the role of emotion in creativity and well-being. Dr. Pringle is an APA fellow and has published more than 150 research studies in top academic journals. Her work has been covered by media outlets including NPR, the Harvard Business Review, Forbes, and many others. Her most recent book is called The Creativity Choice, the Science of Making
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是佐拉娜·伊切维奇·普林格尔博士（Dr. Zorana Ichevich Pringle）。普林格尔博士是耶鲁大学情感智能中心（Yale Center for Emotional Intelligence）的高级研究科学家兼创造力与情感实验室（Creativity and Emotions Lab）主任，她在那里研究情绪在创造力和幸福感中的作用。普林格尔博士是美国心理学协会（APA）会士，并在顶级学术期刊上发表了150多篇研究报告。她的工作受到了NPR、《哈佛商业评论》、《福布斯》等众多媒体的报道。她最近出版的一本书名为《创造力的选择：将想法转化为行动的决策科学》（The Creativity Choice, the Science of Making）。
Decisions to Turn Ideas into Action. Dr. Pringle, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me. So as I said, your book is called The Creativity Choice, and that framing is interesting because a lot of people think of creativity as something you either have or you don't. So what do you mean by calling creativity a choice and how does that change the way we think about our own creative potential? You have mentioned several things that are really important to follow on. We tend to think of creativity as something that we either have or you don't have. And you see how people talk about it in our everyday lives. When I introduce myself at a party and people learn that I study creativity,
决策，将想法付诸行动。普林格尔博士，非常感谢您今天作客我们的节目。谢谢邀请。正如我刚才所说，您的书名叫《创造力的选择》，这个框架很有意思，因为很多人认为创造力是那种要么天生拥有、要么就没有的东西。那么，您将创造力称为一种“选择”是什么意思？这又将如何改变我们对自身创造力潜能的看法呢？你刚才提到的几个问题非常重要，我们可以接着聊。我们往往认为创造力是那种要么天生拥有、要么就没有的东西。看看大家在日常生活中是怎么谈论它的就知道了。当我在派对上自我介绍，别人得知我研究的是创造力时，
often I hear, oh, that is so interesting, but I did not get the creativity gene in the family. That is, then insert a relation or a friend, who inevitably do something that is artistic or in design or in these fields that we label as creative. And even we use the word creative as a noun, as if some people are there. that and other people are not. And what psychologists really mean by creativity is something much broader. It is something that is in the same time both original and effective in a way. And what that original and effective means varies depending on the level of creativity we are discussing, whether that is something in the learning process or something in our
我经常听到这样的话：“哦，那太有趣了，但我家好像没有遗传到创造力基因。”接着，他们就会搬出某位亲戚或朋友，而这些人不可避免地从事着艺术、设计或我们贴上“创造力”标签的领域。甚至我们把“创造力”这个词当作名词来用，好像有些人天生具备这种特质，而其他人则没有。但心理学家所说的创造力要广泛得多。它同时具备两个特点：既有原创性，又在某种程度上行之有效。至于这种“原创且有效”具体意味着什么，会根据我们讨论的创造力层级而有所不同，无论是学习过程中的点滴，还是我们日常生活、职业生涯中的点滴，抑或是能在整个文化中产生巨大影响的事物。
everyday life, in our professional life, or something that can make a big difference in the culture at large. To help our listeners and me, I'm going to ask you how you define creativity, because in my reading of your book, you know, you focus on being able to do something novel and that the execution of the idea is critical to creativity. Am I understanding you right? You are understanding it's very much right. It's an important point that creativity is not just having ideas. There are lots of people who have ideas. We have all set in brainstorming sessions and ideas are flying. So it's not that lack of creativity that we see in the world is because we don't have those. It is something else. It is something that people sometimes call execution, but I think there is much more,
为了帮听众和我自己理清思路，我想问一下您是如何定义创造力的，因为在阅读您的书时，我发现您专注于能够做出新颖的事情，并且想法的执行对于创造力至关重要。我的理解对吗？你的理解非常正确。这是一个很重要的观点，即创造力不仅仅是拥有想法。有很多人都有各种想法。我们都参加过头脑风暴会议，各种想法满天飞。因此，我们在世界上看到的创造力匮乏并不是因为我们缺乏想法。而是另有原因。人们有时称之为“执行”，但我认为这个词的内涵远比表面看到的要丰富。
kind that term than meets the eye. It is a process of making first the decision of whether you are going to engage with it or not, whether it is worth engaging in something that might be carrying some risks, some psychological risks, risk to your reputation, risks to how you see yourself. Can you rise to the challenge? That's an important decision. It's a very first decision in engaging in creative work, but then each different branching is another choice that we can make towards something that is more conventional and easier, essentially easier, because there is a blueprint in how to do it, or something that is more unconventional, has a greater potential for being original, but can be frustrating, can be challenging, can be challenging,
这种词汇的内涵比表面看起来要丰富。这是一个过程：首先要做出决定，看你是否要参与其中，是否值得投入到一件可能带有某种风险的事情中，比如心理风险、对声誉的风险、对自我认知的风险。你能否迎难而上？这是一个重大的决定。这是参与创造性工作的第一步，但随后的每一个分叉路口都是另一种选择：我们可以选择更常规、更容易的路线——本质上更容易，因为有现成的做事蓝图；或者选择更非传统、更有原创潜力的路线，但这个过程可能会令人沮丧，充满挑战，
and we need some emotional skill to address it, to get us through that process. Do you have any favorite examples of creativity and action, especially forms of creativity that people might overlook or not really recognize as creativity? We can look at creativity in different contexts. So we can look at creativity in the learning process, and that is making a connection between something that you are studying
并且我们需要一些情绪调节能力来应对它，帮助我们熬过整个过程。你有没有什么特别喜欢的关于创造力付诸实践的例子？尤其是那些人们可能会忽视、或者并不真正认为那是创造力的形式？我们可以从不同的语境来看待创造力。比如，我们可以看学习过程中的创造力，那是在你正在学习的内容与你的个人经历、或是你已经熟悉的其它领域的知识之间建立联系。那些新的见解就是一种创造力。或者，我们可以看看日常生活中的创造力，解决日常遇到的挑战，我们每个人的日程都很满。我们在任何特定时间都在努力应对非常棘手的事情。举个我自己的例子，几年前，我们面临这样一个挑战：如何安排我们的暑假行程。
and something from a personal experience or from other domains of knowledge that you already familiar with. Those new insights are a form of creativity. Or we can look at creativity in our everyday lives, solving everyday challenges, and we all carry very busy schedules. We have really difficult things we are trying to juggle at any given time. To give you a personal example, a few years ago, we were facing this challenge of how to arrange our summer travel.
因为我和丈夫都是学者，有各种会议和工作要应付。我们的孩子太小，不能独自旅行，但我们又想让他去欧洲看望爷爷奶奶。这些事情看起来似乎无法兼顾。我们该如何让这一切成为现实？我们难道非要在某些选择上做出妥协，放弃别的东西吗？然后我丈夫做了一件他经常做的事，他说：“等等，我们怎么能把这当作一个富有创意的问题来处理呢？”
Because my husband and I are academics and have conferences and obligations. Our child was too young to be traveling on his own, but we wanted him to visit his grandparents in Europe. And it seemed that these things cannot be integrated. How are we going to make it all happen? Do we have to make a choice that we don't want to choose something and not something else? And then my husband did something that he does a lot and he says, wait a second, how can we approach this as a creative problem?
一旦他这么说了，我们开始用不同的方式思考。我们以一种非常规的方式把问题拆解了。因此，我们没有说“两个大人必须陪孩子一起旅行”，而是把问题解决为：一个家长带孩子去欧洲，另一个家长把他接回来。通过这种创意的思维方式，这个极其复杂的问题最终得以解决，对吧，也就是带着创造力的思维模式。或者再给你举一个职业生活中非常不寻常的例子。
And once he said that, we started thinking in a different way. We broke the problem in unobvious ways. So instead of saying both parents have to travel with a child, we solve the problem as one parent takes the child to Europe and the other parent takes him back. And it became possible to solve this really complicated problem in a creative way, right, with the mindset of creativity. Or to give you an unusual, very unusual example from professional life.
我们通常认为职业生活中的创造力属于设计师和研发人员。那医院餐饮部门的主管呢？你能想象他们也有创造力吗？不会立刻这么想。不会立刻这么想，对吧？但事情就是这样的。这个人注意到他的员工们精疲力竭，基本上就是燃尽了。他们感到沮丧。
We think of creativity in professional life as designers and R&D people. What about a supervisor in a food services department of a hospital? Would you imagine that they could be creative? Not immediately. Not immediately, right? But this is what happened. And this person was noticing that his workers were getting burned out, essentially burned out. They were getting frustrated.
他们感到疲惫，非常不开心。而且他们还频频出错。在这个环境中，这些错误至关重要，因为食物是治疗的一部分。你可不想出错，把错误的食物送到错误的人手里。于是他说：“我能从观察他们的沮丧点中学到什么？”这就是情绪发挥作用的地方，也是意想不到的情绪发挥作用的地方。他通过观察意识到，自己可以重新设计工作流程。他彻底重新设计了流程，最后甚至不需要员工们费力去够不同的物品了。
It was, they were getting tired and they were very unhappy. And also they were making mistakes. And these mistakes matter in this context because food is part of treatment. You don't want to be making mistakes and getting wrong people to wrong food to wrong people. And so he said, what can I learn from observing their points of frustration? That's where emotions matter and unexpected emotions matter. And he observed and realized that he can redesign the workflow. And he completely redesigned it to the point that people did not have to stretch anymore
获取不同的物品变得更方便了，他们也不用过度消耗体力。职业倦怠大大减轻。错误也减少了。他表现出了意想不到的创造力。那么，创造力似乎是一件很难通过实验来研究的事情。你和其他研究人员是如何在实验室或现实世界中衡量和研究创造力的呢？
to get different items. It was more convenient. and they were not overexerting physically. Burnout was diminished greatly. The mistakes were reduced. And he was very unexpectedly creative. Now, creativity seems like a difficult thing to study experimentally. How do you and other researchers measure and study creativity in a lab or in the real world?
这是一个极好的问题，也是一个极具挑战性的问题，因为在现实世界中，创造力可能需要几个小时、几天、几周甚至几个月的时间。我们是科学家，而科学家从产生研究想法到将其发表，实际上可能需要几年时间。那么我们该如何应对呢？在实验室里，我们可以研究创意过程的某些部分。因此，我们可以在实验环境中研究人们是如何产生想法的。但我们也非常幸运，生活在一个拥有新技术的时代，这些技术使得研究人们在长期从事某项工作时的表现成为可能。
That is a great question and the very challenging one, because creativity is, is something that in the real world can take hours, days, weeks, months. We are scientists, and scientists from having an idea for a study to publishing it can take several years, actually. So how do we get that? Well, in the lab, we can study certain parts of the creative process. So we can study how people come up with ideas in an experimental setting. But we are also very fortunate to live at a time when we can have technology that makes it possible to study people as they work on something long term.
所以我们有了体验采样技术（experience sampling）。我们在人们的手机上发送通知，问他们：“嘿，你现在这一刻在做什么？你正在处理不同的项目吗？你在收集信息吗？你在和合作者开会吗？你现在的体验是怎样的？你在想些什么？”然后我们可以把这些信息碎片拼凑起来，随着时间的推移进行追踪。
So we have technology of experience sampling. We get notifications of people's phones that ask them, hey, what are you doing right now in this moment? Are you working on different projects? Are you collecting information? Are you in a meeting with collaborators? What is your experience like right now? And what are you thinking about? And then we can piece those pieces of information together and follow it through time.
创造力与解决问题有何关联？它们本质上是同一回事吗？还是说创造性解决问题有什么独特之处？我认为在我们的日常对话中，我们经常把创造力和创造性解决问题或复杂问题解决划等号。它们确实有相似之处。但我认为“创造力”这个词比“解决问题”更广泛。你能说莫奈在画睡莲时是在解决问题吗？
How does creativity relate to problem solving? Are they essentially the same thing? Or is there something distinct about creative problem solving? I think that often in our everyday conversation we equate creativity and creative problem solving or complex problem solving. And there are similarities for sure. But the term creativity, I think, is broader than problem solving. Would you say that Monet was solving a problem when he was painting the water
我们可能不会完全这么用。你会说当你决定必须和孩子发明一个新游戏时，你是在解决问题吗？我们大概也不会这么用。或者在儿童的创造力表现中，当他们在进行假扮游戏——幼儿期创造力的基础形式时，他们是在解决问题吗？所以我认为创造力的概念更广泛，但它包含了解决问题。它包含了创造性解决问题，并且其中涉及许多相同的过程，
lilies? We would probably not quite use that. Would you say that you were solving a problem when you decide to need to invent a new game with your child, probably we would not use that. Or in children's forms of creativity, are there solving a problem when they are engaging in pretend play, that foundational form of creativity in early childhood? So I think the concept of creativity is broader, but it includes problem solving. It includes creative problem solving and lots of the same processes are involved in it,
包括认知和情感过程。我知道以前有人问过你这个问题，但我还是想重复一遍，因为我觉得这是一个好问题。炮制一首“一曲成名”的歌曲（one-hit wonder）与具备持续的创造力之间有什么区别？那个单曲创作者，无论他的作品是什么，是创造力不足，还是仅仅运气好？哦，我喜欢这个问题，因为它是那种没有标准答案的问题。
both cognitive and emotional. I know you've been asked this question before, but I'm going to repeat it because I think it's a good one. What's the difference between producing a one-hit wonder and having consistent creativity? Is the creator of a single hit, whatever that might be, less creative or just lucky? Oh, I love that question because it is one of those questions
作为一名研究创造力的科学家，我很喜欢没有标准答案的问题。所以，我认为持续产出和“一曲成名”之间的一个关键区别在于创造力的社交层面。拥有能够提供支持的社会基础设施——好吧，你有一个想法，你有一款产品，你有一件作品，你做出了一些贡献，现在有了可以为持续创造力提供肥沃土壤的支持体系。你刚才也提到了运气，我认为有必要提及并承认运气，特别是在具有开创性的创造力中，运气占据了重要成分。
where there isn't a single answer. And as a scientist studying creativity, I like when there isn't a single answer. So I think a key difference between doing something consistently and being a one-hit wonder is in the social side of creativity. Having the social infrastructure that can support, okay, you had one idea, you have one product, you have one product, you have contributed something, now there are supports that can be fertile ground for repeated creativity. You also mentioned luck there, and I think it is important to mention luck and acknowledge that especially in groundbreaking creativity, there is an important component of luck.
这在任何程度上都不会贬低人们的贡献。他们仍然必须抓住幸运时刻所提供的机遇。他们仍然必须调动所有的资源。但运气可以在一个非常广阔的层面上去理解，比如你出生的时代正好让你的优势得以开花结果，或者切合了那个时代的需要。它也可以从另一个角度来理解，即你出生在一个不用为生存而战的地方。这些是非常非常基础的运气点。但这也是在正确的时间出现在正确的地点，从而能够获得资源和那个社会基础设施。但这并不贬低这样一个事实：我们仍然需要付出大量的努力去创造、
That does not diminish people's contributions in any way. They still have to act on opportunities provided by the lucky moment. They still have to champion all the resources. But luck can be construed on a very broad level as you are born at a time when your strengths can come to fruition or are appropriate for the times. it can be construed in a different way that you are born in a place where you are not fighting for survival. Those are very, very basic points of luck. But it's also being at the right place at the right time to be able to get the resources and get that social infrastructure. That's not diminish the fact that we still have to put a lot of work and create.
组建团队，并在这些想法的基础上将其变为现实。有时这完全取决于时机。我的意思是，比如那些发明mRNA疫苗的人，他们使用了一种在当时根本没有用武之地的发明，直到突然之间，轰的一声，他们把它们组合在了一起。是的，完全如此。我的意思是，有很多这样的例子。有些例子是纯理论构思出来的，
create teams and build on those ideas to make them happen. And sometimes it's timing. I mean, like the people who had come up with the MRNA vaccines, I mean, they used invention that really hadn't had a use until all of a sudden, boom, they put it together. Yeah, exactly. I mean, there are lots of examples like that. You have examples of things that are conceived theoretically,
但无法通过实验证实，因为我们当时还没有相关技术。我们现在所称的“希格斯玻色子”（hex boson），其理论构想和表述是在上世纪60年代提出的。但直到短短几年前，我们才拥有了相关的技术。所以所有这些都很重要。我们要休息一会儿。回来后，我将与普林格尔博士讨论为什么创造力需要勇气，以及如何克服创造力瓶颈。
but cannot be confirmed experimentally because we don't have the technology, the idea, theoretical formulation of what we now call the hex boson was made in the 60s. But just a few years ago, we had the technology. So all of that is important. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Pringle about why creativity requires courage and about how to get past creative blocks.
你是不是那种在幻灯片和电子表格之间点来点去的媒体策略人？是吗？很好。这段话正是为你准备的。因为在Spotify上，有着一群与众不同的受众。他们全神贯注、忠诚度高、投入度深。他们被称为粉丝。粉丝不只是听音乐。他们从音乐中看到自己，觉得音乐属于他们。因此，当你的品牌出现在Spotify上时，你就是在和这样的人对话。而且你就挨着像我这样的艺人，比如莉佐（Lizzo）。所以，你准备好和粉丝对话了吗？Spotify广告。让你置身粉丝之中。大家好。我是凯莉·克拉克森（Kelly Clarkson），与Wayfair合作。你有没有在网上买过家具，然后心里犯嘀咕：“万一……”比如，万一它不经用呢？
Are you one of those media strategy people clicking through slides, scrolling spreadsheets? Yes? Good. This is for you. Because on Spotify, there's an audience that's different. Locked in, loyal, invested. They're called fans. Fans don't just listen to music. They feel seen by it, like it belongs to them. So when your brand shows up on Spotify, that's who you're talking to. And you're right next to artists like me, Lizzo. So, are you ready to talk to fans? Spotify advertising. You're among fans. Hey, y'all. It's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
那张沙发才买四天呢。你当时真该在Wayfair买。在Wayfair，没有“万一”。只有你喜爱的风格和你可以信赖的品质。请访问Wayfair.ca。Wayfair，各种风格，每个温馨的家。现在，你在书中提到创造力需要勇气。你为什么这么认为？
That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. Now, you say in your book that creativity requires courage. Why do you think that?
嗯，什么是勇气？勇气就是一种愿意行动的意愿，哪怕你对某事感到害怕，哪怕这种感觉并不舒服。有时我听到我们文化中的交流将其表述为“你必须学会习惯不舒适”。但我实际上并不知道“习惯不舒适”是什么意思。既然是不舒适，你就无法对它感到舒适。所以我不太确定这种表述是否真的有帮助。
Well, what is courage? Courage is the willingness to act, even if you are afraid of something, even if it is not comfortable. And sometimes I hear in the communication in our culture that be formulated as you have to become comfortable with discomfort. But I don't actually know what being comfortable with discomfort means. If it's discomfort, you're not comfortable with it. So I am not sure that that formulation really helps.
我认为我们只需要承认，在创造过程中有时会有不愉快的时刻，它们具有挑战性，而且我们正在把头伸出去冒险。因为根据它的定义，如果我们旨在做一些原创的事情，那么它必须在某种程度上不同于以往的做法。因此我们无法预知它会受到怎样的反响。我们无法确知它能否完全按照我们想象的那样被实现。这些都是风险，而这些风险会让人感到不适。所以勇气就是承认这些风险的存在，并尽管感到不适依然采取行动。并且愿意接受别人说“那个想法行不通”或者“你疯了吗，你为什么要走这条路”之类的质疑。
I think that we just have to acknowledge that there are times in the creative process that are not pleasant and that they're challenging and that we are sticking our head out. Because by its very definition, if we are aiming to do something original, well, it has to be different from what has been done before in some fashion. and therefore we cannot know how it is going to be received. We cannot know can it be done exactly how we imagine it. Those are the risks and those risks are uncomfortable. So the courage is to acknowledge that they exist and to act in spite of that discomfort. And to be willing to accept when people say that idea won't work or you're out of your mind, why are you going this way?
是的，有时它确实行不通，但有时人们并没有意识到它是可行的，在你听到一声“Yes”之前，你可能会听到无数次“No”。同样在你的书中，你谈到了创造力的不同层级。你称它们为mini-c、pro-c和大C（Big C）。这些术语是什么意思？我们在刚才的谈话中其实已经暗示过这些了。当我提到学习过程中的创造力时，那就是mini-c创造力。那是仅仅相对于你个人以往经验而言具有原创性的创造力。也许
Yeah, and sometimes it cannot work, but sometimes people are not aware that it could, and you get no a number of times before you get a yes. Also in your book, you talk about different levels of creativity. You call them mini-C, pro-C, and big C. What do those terms mean? We already hinted at those in our conversation. So when I mentioned creativity in the learning process, that is miniser. creativity. That is creativity that is original just in relation to your previous experience. Maybe
其他人以前也建立过这种联系，但对你而言，它是原创且有意义的。在小c（Little C）层面上，它是指那些日常互动、日常问题解决以及日常灵感迸发。也许你有一个爱好。也许你打开冰箱，外面正在刮暴风雪，现在你必须就手头仅有的东西进行对付。而在pro-c层面上，我们讨论的是需要专业知识的创造力。如果你在编写软件，你实际上需要知道如何编写代码；如果你是一名科学家，你实际上需要知道如何进行科学研究，以此类推。至于大C（Big C），大C是指那些巨匠，当我们听到“创造力”这个词时首先想到的名字，比如这个世界的克劳德·莫奈（Claude Monet）、文森特·梵高（Van Gogh）、史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）以及
somebody else has made that connection before, but for you it is original and meaningful. On the Little C level, it is those everyday interactions, everyday problem solving, and everyday points of inspiration. Maybe you have a hobby. Maybe you are opening the fridge and there was a snowstorm and now you have to deal with what you have to deal with. And then on the pro C level, we are talking about creativity that takes expertise. You actually need to know how to code if you are writing a piece of software, you actually have to know how to conduct scientific research if you are a scientist and so on. And Big C, Big C is those giants, those names that first come to mind when we hear the word creativity, the Claude Monet's of this world and the Van Gogh's and Steve Jobs's and
可可·香奈儿（Coco Chanel）。其他人是如何影响我们的创造力的？比如说，如果你正试图为一个问题寻找创造性的解决方案，什么时候将其他人引入这个过程才是有帮助的？人们在群体中更有创造力，还是作为独立个体时更有创造力？哦，我认为这里面包含了两个不同的问题。当我们从事某项工作时，即使我们是在独立工作，比如如果你在写一本书，如果没有代笔作家，你就是在自己一个人完成。
Coco Chanel's. How do other people influence our creativity? Like say you're trying to come up with a creative solution to a problem, when is it helpful to bring others into the process and are people more creative in groups or as solo practitioners? Oh, there are, I think, two different questions that are embedded in this one. When we are working on something, even if we are working on something on our own, like if you're writing a book, you are, if you don't have a ghostwriter, you are doing it on your own. own. So you are sitting, like I was sitting writing my book in Barnes & Noble and in front of my computer. So it sounds like that kind of creativity is not social, but in reality it is because ideas and ways of thinking do not come out of vacuum. They come from interactions, past, present,
所以你坐着，就像我当时坐在巴诺书店（Barnes & Noble）电脑前写书一样。所以听起来这种创造力似乎不具社交性，但实际上它是社交性的，因为想法和思维方式并非凭空产生。它们来自于与同事、与我们在这个根本上具有社交性的世界中的经历之间的互动——无论是过去的、现在的，还是潜在的互动。所以这是其中一种社会影响，而另一个人的影响有时是通过我们拥有的那些经历以及这些经历的广度隐式体现出来的。如果我们正专门解决一个问题，在不同阶段向不同的人寻求帮助会有所帮助。因此，如果我们正在寻找新的想法，向那些你不常交谈的人求助真的很有帮助。比如那些可能不在你团队里的人、不是你亲密朋友或同事的人，因为你已经知道你亲密的朋友和同事是怎么想的了。如果你在构思新想法，你需要不同的视角。
implied with colleagues, with our experiences in a fundamentally social world. So that is one kind of social influence and other people whose influence is sometimes implied by those experiences we have and the breadth of those experiences. If we are specifically working on a problem, reaching out to different people can help in different stages. So if we are looking for new ideas, it really helps to reach out to people you don't often talk to. So people who might not be on your team, people who are not close friends or colleagues, because you already know how your close friends and colleagues think. And if you are thinking of new ideas, you need different perspectives.
向那些你可能一年见一次面、或者处于你社交圈边缘的人寻求帮助会非常有用。他们可能会问你一个“如果……会怎样”的问题，而你甚至不知道自己一直在寻找这个答案。如果你已经有了一个想法，并且已经投入其中，现在你只需要帮助来更深入地开发它。与那些与你亲近、已经了解你思维方式的人合作会非常有用。因此，如果你是职场中的经理，你如何营造一个能激励员工发挥创造力的环境？你通过首先建立创造力最根本的社会和情感基石来营造这种环境，那就是心理安全感。这个词在我们的文化中被大量使用，但有时其方式可能会产生误导。
And it will be really helpful to reach to those who maybe you see once a year or maybe are the outskirts of your social circles. they might ask you the what-if question that you didn't even know you were after. And if you already have an idea, you are committed to it, now you just need help to develop it in more depths. Working with those who are close to you, who already know how you are thinking is going to be really helpful. So if you're a manager in a workplace, how can you create an environment that motivates people to be created? You create the environment by first creating the most fundamental social and emotional building block of creativity, and that is psychological safety. And that word is used a lot in our culture, but sometimes in ways that might be misleading.
因此，心理安全感并不意味着你有权在任何时候说出脑海中冒出的任何话。它的意思是你可以分享你的想法和意见，而不必担忧或害怕遭到报复。这并不意味着可以不考虑他人及其感受，因为那样的话我们讨论的就是尊重的问题。但一旦你有了这种氛围，你就会听到各种各样的想法。你会开始听到不同的视角，那些赞同你的视角和不赞同你的视角。如果你听到的只有赞同，这就是缺乏安全感的诊断信号。当经理问“大家有什么问题吗”而无人提问时，这就说明你没有这种安全感。是的，我在引言中稍微谈到了人工智能，我知道人工智能正在越来越深地融入我们的个人和职业生活。在人工智能时代，你认为人类创造力的角色是什么？你认为人工智能会增强还是削弱创造力？这是一个没有标准答案的问题。
So psychological safety does not mean you have the permission to say whatever comes to mind at any point. it means that you can share your ideas and your opinions without having a concern or a fear that you're going to be retaliated against. And it does not mean without consideration for others and their feelings because then we are dealing with an issue of respect. But once you have this atmosphere, then you are going to hear ideas. you're going to start hearing different perspectives, those that agree with you and those that disagree with you. If you only hear agreement, it's diagnostic that you don't have the safety. When a manager says, are there any questions and there are no questions, you do not have the safety. Yeah, I talked a little bit in the intro about artificial intelligence, and I know AI is becoming
我认为它会以不同的方式兼而有之。有时候，运用类比进行思考会很有帮助，尤其是当我们面对某种从根本上改变我们生活和与世界相处方式的事物时。因此，让我们借用过去技术的两个不同比喻。当19世纪摄影术被发明时，有很多文章称这将是绘画的终结。它将导致艺术的终结和绘画的终结。
more and more of our personal and professional lives. What do you see as the role of human creativity in the age of AI? And do you think AI is going to enhance or detract from creativity? This is one of those questions that there isn't a single answer to. I think that it's going to do all of the above in different ways. I think it helps to think in analogies sometimes, especially when we are dealing with something that is fundamentally changing how we live and deal with the world. So let's take two different analogies with technologies of the past. When photography was invented in the 19th century, there was a lot of writing about it being the end of painting. It's going to bring about the end of art and the end of painting.
好吧，它并没有导致绘画的终结。可以说是恰恰相反，涌现出了许多非常原创的新绘画流派，它们说：“嘿，为什么不尝试以更抽象的方式，而不是像我们平时所看到的那样来描绘世界呢？”所以它并没有带来终结。然后，回到你问题的另一部分——它是好是坏？想想社交媒体。我们在很大程度上都在讨论社交媒体带来的所有问题。但它带来的并不仅仅是问题。
Well, it did not bring up an end of painting. Sort of quite to the contrary, new schools of painting emerged that were very original, that were saying, hey, how about not portraying the world as we see it, but in more abstract ways. So it didn't do that. And then they were to get to the part of your question of, is it going to be good or is it going to be bad? Think of social media. We are discussing social media a lot in terms of all the problems it brought up. But it didn't bring about just problems.
它还促进了交流。它还使我们能够重新建立那些平时可能会忽视的人际关系。它以原本不可能的方式促进了沟通和组织。这并不是要否认它的负面影响，但这是一个复杂的问题。所以我认为创造力也会发生类似的情况。这将取决于我们在自身周围建立的、以及存在于我们的组织和工作场所中的社会结构。有一件事在某种程度上确实让我感到欣慰，那就是关于创造力和人工智能的最新研究表明，人工智能本身会抹平创意。
It also enabled communication. It also enabled reconnecting with relationships we normally would have neglected. it enabled communicating and organizing in a way that otherwise would not be possible. That is not to deny its negative effects, but it's a complicated question. So I think a similar thing is going to happen with creativity. It's going to depend on that social structure we build around ourselves and that exist in our organizations and places of work. The one thing that really is comforting to me in a way is the emerging research on creativity and AI shows that AI on its own flattens creative ideas.
它能产生很多想法，所以看起来非常令人印象深刻，但这些想法在原创性方面差不多都处于中等水平。而且，你知道，真正能带来改变的创造力并不在于平均水平。它在于那些更不落俗套的东西。而且我们仍然是提出问题的人。我们仍然是提供提示词的人。我们仍然是说“不，换个方式怎么样”并创造方向的人。现在的研究表明，本身就具有较高创造潜能的人类在与人工智能互动时，能够增强创造力；而那些本身不具备这些初始创造力的人，最终的创造力反而会变低。现在，我们中的一些人有时会遇到某种创作瓶颈，比如写作瓶颈。你有什么建议可以帮助人们度过那些时刻吗？
It produces a lot of ideas, so it seems very impressive, but those ideas are somewhere around the mid-level of how original they are. And, you know, creativity that makes a difference is not about the average. It's about something that is more unconventional. And we are still the ones asking the questions. We are still the ones who give it prongs. We are still the ones who say no, how about, and create direction. And now the research is showing that once humans who have greater creative potential, themselves interact with AI, they are able to enhance creativity and those who don't have those
创作瓶颈每个人都会遇到。事实上，创作瓶颈的科学定义是：并非由于缺乏技能而导致的进展停滞。因此，当你经历创作瓶颈时，提醒自己：嘿，心理科学告诉我们，这并非由于缺乏技能，因此这只是暂时的。现在，即使你知道它是暂时的，你仍然希望加快进度，并希望继续取得进展。你可以做几件事。所以你能做的第一件事，就是让自己跳出那个情绪激活点。
starting creative abilities end up being less creative. Now, some of us experience some kind of creative block from time to time, like writer's block, for example. Do you have advice to get people past those moments? Creative blocks happen to everybody. And actually, the scientific definition of a creative block is lack of progress that is not due to lack of skill. So when you experience a creative block, remind yourself, hey, psychological science tells us it is not due to lack of skill, therefore this is temporary. Now, even if you know it is temporary, you still want to speed it up and you want to continue making progress. And there are a few things you can do. So the first thing that you can do is get yourself out of that emotional activation point.
因为如果你正在经历创作瓶颈，那会令人感到无比沮丧。对某些人来说，这会增加自我怀疑。而对另一些人来说，这种情绪甚至会发展到自我厌恶的地步。当我问及不同领域专业从事创意工作的人时，这种体验的强烈程度可以说是相当惊人的。因此，研究情绪的人发现了一个巧妙的小技巧。采用第三人称视角，想象这并不是发生在你身上。
Because if you are experiencing a creative block, it's overwhelmingly frustrating. And for some people, it's going to increase self-doubt. When some people, it can go all the way to self-loathing. And when I ask people who are creative professionally in different domains, the range of this experience can get pretty intense. So there is a trick in a way that people who study emotions have identified. Taking the third person perspective, imagine that this is not happening to you.
想象一下，一个非常亲爱的朋友正在向你解释他们身上发生了什么，而他们所描述的正是你现在的处境。他们现在卡壳了。他们原本取得了进展，一切都很顺利。而现在他们已经两天没有写出一个字了，他们不知道该怎么办。你会对那个人说什么？好吧，你会对那个人说……
Imagine that a very dear friend is explaining what is going on with them and they are describing what is going on with you. They are now stuck. They were making progress. It was going well. And now they haven't written a word in two days and they don't know what to do. What would you tell that person? Well, you would tell that person.
你会向他们展示一些善意。你不会对他们说：“哼，你本来应该表现得更好的。”我们总是对自己说：“你本该表现得更好的。”我们对自己说：“你本可以采取不同的做法。”但我们不会对朋友这样说。我们会提醒他们这只是暂时的。我们会提醒他们已经尽力了。
You would show them some kindness. You would not tell them, well, you should have known better. We tell ourselves you should have known better. We tell ourselves that you could have a lot of, should have done something differently. But we don't tell that to a friend. We remind them that it is temporary. We remind them that they are doing their best.
我们甚至可能会建议他们：“嘿，休息一下吧。”这就是我们真正应该做的第二件事。休息一下。休息一下，去做点事情——不一定只是去散散步。不只是去看会儿Netflix。这仍然需要付出一些努力。这仍然需要你做一些工作。为什么这很重要呢？因为当你投入到另一个你没有被卡住的问题中时，
And we might even suggest to them, hey, take a break. And that is the second thing we should really do. Take a break. Take a break and do something that is not just going for a walk necessarily. It's not just going to watch some Netflix. it still takes some effort. It still takes some work on your part. And why that matters is that as you are engaged in some other problem that you are not stuck on,
好吧，你会在那个问题上取得进展，所以你的负罪感就会减少。但另一件事是，你的大脑将从你卡住的那部分专注中解放出来。这样可以让它得到某种休息。在这种情况下，新的联系往往会以近乎神奇的方式简单地融合在一起，从而带来灵光一现的“顿悟”时刻。所以最后，我想向《心理学说话》的大多数嘉宾提出这样一个问题：
well, you are going to be making progress on that problem, so you are going to feel less guilty. But another thing is that you will free your mind from focusing on the part that you are stuck on. And it can give it kind of a rest that way. And in those circumstances, new connections often simply merge in ways that seem almost magical and those aha moments of sudden insight. So just to wrap up, I'd like to ask this question of most of the people on speaking of
你接下来要做什么？你现在在研究什么？还有哪些重大问题亟待解答？我的重大问题依然是：我们如何弥合“拥有一个想法”与“用它做点什么并将其变为现实”之间的鸿沟。但现在我正在以不同的方式看待它。我正在探索这个过程，本质上其实是一个自我调节的过程。这是一个在“我是继续探索、广泛思考并钻进某些思维死胡同”，还是“我现在就进行投入和专注”之间做出抉择的过程。
psychology. What's next for you? What are you working on now? what are the big questions that remain to be answered? My big question is still how do we bridge that gap from having an idea to doing something with it and to making it real. But now I'm looking at it in a different way. I am exploring that process is a process that is fundamentally about self-regulation. It's a process of making a decision between do I continue exploring and do.
这通常是一个来回往复的过程。因此，我正在探索我们是如何在创造性工作的这些不同拉锯之间保持平衡的。普林格尔博士，非常感谢您今天作客我们的节目。这次访谈非常有趣且受益匪浅。谢谢邀请。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或你获取播客的任何地方收听《心理学说话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢我们的话，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有什么意见或想法，可以发邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。本期《心理学说话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。感谢收听。
thinking broadly and going into some rabbit holes, or do I now commit and focus? And it is often a back and forth process. So I am exploring how we are balancing those different pools of creative work. Dr. Pringle, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very interesting and helpful. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of speaking of psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at a.pa.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening.
我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学协会向您致意。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯，这里是美国心理学会播客。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。